[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hello hello we're here how's
it going yeah you gotta get right up
into the mic what's up everybody
purcha here and I'm joined by clockwerk
the cameras right there this is our
screen buttface news here yeah what's up
everybody let me turn down the game
volume a little bit they can hear us a
little better today we're gonna be
playing some Power Rangers battle for
the grid with combat designer clockwork
Daniel Maniago holdin it down um if you
guys do not know who clockwork is he is
a legendary fighting game player many
many years in the game so it's pretty
awesome that he's making his own
fighting games now kind of kind of the
dream maybe you can say so right we were
talking the other day about it how it's
like kind of surreal surreal you're
making your own game now but it's pretty
well yeah so yeah a fighting gamer
making a fighting game especially a
Marvel player making a fight game you
already know it's gonna be in-depth
intricate but also the cool thing about
battle through the grid is it's also
kind of user friendly so so that's
exciting new update just came out brand
spankin new also free so go download it
you get three new characters there's
also been a little bit of balance patch
with the combat system and story mode
has been implemented what else am I
missing anything else yeah I mean story
mode we have a you know vo from actual
original Power Rangers cast I'll go over
it in a bit we have combat changes new
stages new characters yeah so you can
download the 1.2 patch today on
PlayStation and Xbox and Nintendo switch
the patch comes out soon yeah
so exciting stuff lots on the way for
Power Rangers and you know we were also
talking about this but this is the
scheme you made it you release it but
once it's in the hands of other fighting
game players it turns into a whole new
mom yeah I mean it's crazy because you
know what we we designed the characters
you say you know they're gonna do this
this and this and this but it's not
until it sort of gets out into the wild
where people have you know instant
amount of people with infinite amount of
time to just find every penny of the
game like Oh what you could do that you
know so it's really it's really
interesting you know we just had the
patch come out a few days ago and it's
it's crazy when you see people come up
with stuff or strategies or combos that
you know I you know it makes sense
but it's like wow I didn't realize you
could do that with that you know it's
it's really it's really awesome yeah it
was really important to us to create a
system that was open-ended enough to
sort of create that emerging gameplay
and in a fighting game that takes the
shape of crazy combos yeah isn't you
didn't even you know think of and that's
sort of how you get ahead when playing
against other people online or in person
so it was really important to us to sort
of have that freeform
fighting game combat yeah crazy with it
yeah it's really cool and I mean if you
guys want to see some of these crazy
combos just go on Twitter twitter is
like a treasure trove of stuff I'm
actually if you sign into my profile so
we can check out story mode first okay
but yeah that's our little introduction
you guys thanks for tuning in everyone
in the chat thank you for being here
hello Dylan thank you for stopping by
and everyone else box night is back
what's up hey crime good to see you
again and everyone else just thank you
so much for coming through you have to
sign in though so story mode has just
been added we're gonna play maybe one or
two matches just so you guys can get a
little bit of taste of the story mode
and then we're gonna jump into some
patch updates check out these new
characters and then we're gonna play
online so if you guys want to play
against clockwork online
come on bring it on yeah yes we are good
we're gonna check out some story action
so 12 battles is that the whole or is
that just for the prologue you have to
have to find out
Zordon is gone the Rangers and their
last stand have been crushed
you've taken the white light for
yourself this is a big day Lord dragon
[Music]
very good his face thank you for all
that we have accomplished you don't see
I've had a lot on my mind
tell me child what troubles
Zordon shows children for a reason their
hope their optimism man this is deep
they're not even a their ability to be
controlled being I don't even know that
was a word you know they're straight
shot us the Jason David phrase is no
Green Ranger eventually every child
really pulled a bottle the boys
you gave me these powers
it's only fitting
Tommy what happened to you she's always
getting herself into something too just
like the words bagging all right what's
the word Jason are we going again or you
calling it quits before we get out to
the VSO for the story mode again we have
original power interest cast of doing
the voice itself
Jason David Frank of course the Green
Ranger you know one of my heroes as a
kid
also Austin st. John the Red Ranger
original Red Ranger right we also have
David fielding who did the voice resort
on you know and Carrigan Mahon with
Goldar and of course a strawberry 17
Meghan Camarena just Kimberly so shadow
saw the vo yeah yeah I think it's pretty
awesome when you know voice actors from
television production versions like they
get involved with the game bridge and
see oh that's so dope yeah yeah I
apologize so there's so much cop new
continent yeah yeah seriously uh but
also so for those I don't know you know
Power Rangers comics are really popular
especially these days and he's a writer
director very famous comic book guy Kyle
Higgins he did Mighty Morphin Power
Ranger shattered grid he did Batman
Nightwing so yeah he's huge and also the
illustrations that you seeing in the
game come not only from the very
talented artists that anyway but also
from Dan Denmark yeah I'm not really
I'll be honest I thought watching Power
Rangers and a witty kid but they're
still going strong yeah
let's go let's do this if you've got the
time to be you always I can't believe it
light combat ooh bottom region back to
action let's go oh you see that grace
yeah we just doing some sparring oh no I
have your controls okay
[Music]
jumbled up in my head fun fact also
clockwork plays on a hitbox was taking
this even weirder wrong wrong controls
and those steak
yeah hitbox is pretty cool crime says
can you share funny moments about
developments funny moments about
development oh my god so I'll be honest
you know the when I first joined the
project was still really early in
development sort of hats like design and
yeah as it turns out Green Ranger was
the very first character that I designed
and then we went further on and further
on into development I realized that
because he was the first character I
designed he was probably the most wack
and boring character and I was like it's
Joe stressing me out so much like oh man
he's like the most popular character yes
yeah so I took some extra time out to
sort of go over his design again and I
got to a place where his combos felt
really good we have to add that the
dragons are super into it so yeah games
a frat you you learn a lot as you go and
yeah I hope everyone enjoys a Green
Ranger in the game let's begin the devil
got your boy or a big yeah hey you were
supposed to be here like an hour ago
should that you have been the vo
Australian doubles you two against me
whoa whoa whoa you think I need Tommy to
be you to hire you tomorrow to do Bo I
mean you did so it's like that huh I uh
you know standing right here
so start moving easy easy
Paul golden says st. Claude games
amazing awesome that's probably have to
be like super rewarding as a combat
designer but really like your game I
mean we try our best with it again you
know
the game should always be kids can
always be better and improved upon we're
continuing continue we need to work on
the game working really hard so yeah
please stick with us they're gonna get
better yeah shoutouts all all the fans
everyone that's been tweeting us
creating content you know giving us
feedback it's yeah it's really
appreciated you know we listen I've read
every inch of the internet game you know
just let me know how you feel okay okay
I surrender you got a tough team same
time tomorrow some one-on-one oh dang
Tommy I mean I already got my training
in for the day you want me to stay for
extra you need to at least make it
interesting well okay so how about
whoever wins gets to pick the movie the
car reaches 2017 movies i watch whoa
whoa whoa hold on a second who said I
wanted to go see a movie no I didn't
mean that is if you don't want to that's
uh you know Tommy I'm kidding
that's it you have terrible taste in
movies well then I guess you better
bring your A game quote unquote a game
like I have anything but a game this guy
all right so we'll let them release this
tension real quick and then we'll check
out some of the racism um talks about
some patch of these Kimberly so freaking
no no this is a 3v3 game so that's
probably why you guys have like the
multiple life phrase at the moment
ranges between one on one in the story
oh oh no ranges racism I am detecting an
incoming transmission from anniversary
know what's happening what's going on
don't worry no one can get into the
command dinner without a power cook
oh no power quois yes
Zardoz idea of security they didn't save
him in my world they won't save him in
yours who are you supposed to be Oh
Tommy
so naive I have your destroyer dude his
voice Tommy he sounds just like you know
what I take back my question I don't
care who you are why you're here or how
you've got to I don't even know what to
call this knockoff sex yeah we'll go
with that and this is a knockoff Frieza
that snack all right you know what we're
gonna have to let our viewers hold the
anticipation right here
yeah yeah ooh and we're starting to get
to see some some more characters dude
the henchmen but yeah tune in next time
to see what happens exactly next week
next episode of battle through the grid
yeah that's cool I like it and I like
that it's in that kind of little comic
book II style too yeah yeah yeah I think
people really enjoy it we've got some
good feedback online so far yeah I'm
really looking forward to sequels
reactions to story yeah sure yeah hope
you guys enjoyed the little sneak peek
of the story mode like you said free
update so if you have the game please go
download it and play yeah and if you
don't have the game it's only 20 bucks
oh yeah we're all about the deals take a
few nights off a Denny's that Grand Slam
oh no I hit the share button share
button that let me actually let's
present there and by the way I have to
go back I think that so I think you have
to like yeah yeah I'm hitting start
waiting like a minute ago Marty is our
oh okay
yeah yeah so big patch this games been
out for a little while now but they just
had a big patch so talk to us all about
it I know you said it was like yeah way
different yeah yeah there's no way that
I could even talk about off the top of
my head yeah there's so much yeah and
again before I get into the patch notes
yeah a bunch of new content vo we have a
story mode right we have no new
characters we have new stages yeah
please check it out and for those
fighting game players in the industry
and I want to get into the nitty gritty
nitty gritty of the patch notes you can
actually check them out on battle for
the grid calm but I'll go over some of
the more the huge stuff here
yeah the presses yeah yes sure so again
we have new new characters right
Cenozoic Blue Ranger LaDonna and
dragon armor Trini right let me see what
are some good stuff sighs maybe we
should have picked her for this for the
stream sake Oh
Trini yeah you got it
so yeah one of the big things that we
wanted to of course the new characters
just super cool by the way and if you
haven't played like this game at all I
think all the characters are really cool
they're pretty unique yeah yeah it is
important to us that they all sort of
fill their role on the slog right so
hopefully there's something something
there for you something there's some
character for everyone in the game break
everything from rushdown characters to
keep away characters by set of
characters easy to use or technical
characters right so of course you know
there's a lot of we've had a lot of bug
fixes like sweeping you know as many
bugs as we can stamp out and we also had
an issue where now if so for example if
you call your assist car your system so
we had this thing where oh you get hit
by sorry so if I if I not push it out
and I start hitting a harrasses
character after her character is dead
the character would sort of assist would
stay in and I can beat them to death
even now we just put a hard limit on you
get 5 seconds to beat up on useless I'm
from the Marvel 2 days right yeah yeah
yeah yeah we want to seize up on that
abyss only give you know
a little bit of time to beat upon
character this game does do some
significant damage already we see yeah
yeah there's a book just look at Twitter
yeah and we've also had we reduced the
meter game about by about 25% oh you
have to be sort of a little bit more
strategic right your meter use also
because the supers are on the scale yeah
scale damage right so it's really it's
really about learning the characters
combo limits and making sure you can
squeeze in like a super at the end or if
you're really clever at the beginning
and combo afterwards you know yeah so
we've reduced the the meter game we've
also reduced meter gain for when you get
hit by stuff right so I think in the
whole in the old version if I call my
dragon Zord and you like get hit or
block just huge scale I think your meter
when I drew you know so we wanted to
sort of reduce that have a bit more
reasonable amount of meter game from
from when you get hit by attacks we've
also adjusted some of the impulse on
unblocking so it'll look a little bit
more natural when you block air attacks
sort of the direction that you would
expect yeah what else we got here okay
so another change that we've made is
that I think in the in one point to the
old patch if I have my Megazord active
and you start comboing me in certain
situations I can like have my Megazord
do like a combo breaker I hit you in the
middle bit but that's no longer the case
so now if I have my Megazord out and you
start comping me I'm sort of stuck
eating your combo so I'm ready to ever
cover and I can when I'm recovering so
if I'm getting up or if I'm out of the
combo then I can start calling my
Megazord again so it's sort of like a
bigger risk reward when using your
Megazord and that's the whole strategy
right is that if I have my Megazord out
and I'm going sort of willy-nilly if you
are sort of keen on that then you can
you know surprise attack me get me in a
super and all that and
it wastes my [ __ ] overtime you know
what I mean so you thought you know it's
menses or the mega stars are meant to
give you an edge in battle but you swap
yeah I just go crazy
yeah and that's and that's for all three
Megazords of course all the characters
let's see what else we got here
so a meter based attacks such as supers
DX moves they ignore the juggle limiter
so if you end a really really long combo
that's about to set off the juggle
emiram so those are the chat that don't
know there are two systems in place that
are preventing sort of undesirable
infinite sand loops one of them is the
juggle limiter so certain attacks they
add to account in which once you reach
the threshold you'll flip out of the
combo and on the ground we have histone
deterioration so me a lot of modern
fighting games do that where the hits
done starts getting less and less and
less as a combo gets further and further
along even have a meter right there the
Sun time yeah yeah but what this change
did is that if you learn for your
character getting sort of at the the
limit of your combo if you do if you end
the combo with an X the X or the super
is guaranteed to not set off that jokah
limiter so we make sure that the combo
Enders and guaranteed injuries that's
cool yeah so this is never gonna flip
out guarantee tender and guaranteed
damage I like it about the damage and
see what else we got here so the X
attacks we've increased the invincible
frames across the board to reduce the
likelihood of assistive tech blowing
through phase one of the attack so a lot
of the e^x attacks for those who don't
know if he pressed light and special at
the same time you get to see it
you'll know because you're glowing and
you have a screen pause and this is an
invincible attack so you use it not just
to end combos but use it defensively
because of instability so we've sort of
increased invincibility frame window so
that you know it's a 3v3 game and
assists are flying all over the place
right know what I mean so you want to
make sure that when you use your EXO
tech it really helps you to get out of
attention and not have this issue when
the invincibility is already worn on the
changes but it's good because you know
now that the game has been Allen's been
in the hands of people they probably
help you find things you need to change
too so we have the system where we have
all the characters have target combos
where if you mash you know lll and then
HH you get sort of yeah a special target
combo normally at the end of these
target combos you can't cancel into
special moves because it's sort of like
an India combo however you can cancel
them into exs leaders across the board I
think there's something which was
refitted before so we want to sort of
open up the combo system that way a big
one for advanced players is that we've
made an tires reversal so I'll go into
the antarious isn't really quick so
something unique to our game is that air
blocking is automatic so if you hold up
your RT air but I did not know that yeah
yeah crossing days across unders those
all those oh yeah those blocks to you so
you still have to
if I had shown the ground though
yourself yeah this is sort of a funny
story so one of the things that we went
for in this game was sort of removing
certain gates for newer players so one
of those is like special moves are done
with one button right another of those
things is that you can run just by
holding forward instead of you know
gating at the time to forward forward
input right so it's players who aren't
you know you don't really aren't really
looking for you know to be fighting game
masters whenever they can at least jump
into the game and do their thing and
honestly this I feel like this type of
game with all of that will help people
be better fine game players in general
and because there are more intricate
things in this game to learn absolutely
but you don't need that to start which
is really convenient yeah you don't need
to start and you don't need to have the
dexterity of a you know professionally
trained pianist or whatever to you to do
your thing so yeah again we didn't want
to gate certain stuff behind inputs
which I know that will you're gonna
scare advanced players off and one day
you know we were shady K and II's
another comment designer that I work
with a very famous Marvel player we were
trying to fix a bug and what we came to
is that air blocking was automatic and
we were thinking like well game to have
air buck what do you do you jump up and
you start holding back immediately
why why even do that right like why
would you just let people
let's go him yeah just let him block in
the air and so if you walk in here you
have blocks automatically for you the
only way that you're gonna get is if ya
pressing something right and the other
way you're gonna get hit is getting anti
aired so anti airs they have every
character has at least one they have the
special property of going through being
invincible to air attacks and they are
not air blockable so Sam if you jump
straight up and down yeah so you can't
right so what happens is the way the
meta is developing is that you know we
have these ee-excuse right
if I knock you down right the first
thing you want to do is start e^x on the
way up so that all right excellent on
your wakeup so that you know you're
talking about pressure so what people do
response to that is they sort of jump up
and try to bait your e^x I like that
okay so what we've done is we've made
anti errors have reversal properties so
I can sort of buffer an anti-air as I'm
getting up so that people try to jump
straight up yeah say I trust you every
time you hit me on the way yeah and it's
it's a whole like sort of like paper
weighted hitbox is a thing we're on yeah
on my wake up on your wake up I'm gonna
either you know jump up and try it to
fate you're your ex but you can't hire
me if you know I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna call my sister try to cover it you
can't call yours so it's a big change
for advanced players so I want to remind
everyone that's been playing Power
Rangers battle for the grid that used
your anti-air air attack invincible
right people are jumping all over the
place you want to answer and punish them
learn the optimal combo off of your anti
I'll go over a few more of these
especially with the air blocking being
Mele that is and they an tiring
definitely is more important to me now
compared to like five minutes ago before
I knew that interesting I like this we
have a few fireballs that were low
before they're no longer our dragon and
Red Ranger they're fire bro fireballs
are no longer low we've also changed a
bit of the way that characters come in
after getting ko door after getting swap
strike we've also reduced the timer on
PvP matches so if you go into arcade
mode or story mode then the timer is
still 300 seconds but in actual versus
mode online or local play it's down to
200 seconds so you might see a timeout
here and there and then another big one
it's not it's kind of a subtle changes
if I have a happy birthday which means
if I'm hitting two of your characters at
once
it would sort of double up on the jungle
limiter and hit some deterioration in a
while and then you know we have some
individual changes you can get the same
combo yeah yeah we have some small
character change I'll just go through
this stuff really quick
Goldar we've reduced some of the damage
on his super increase some of the damage
scaling increment we changed his gust a
bit so that it doesn't like always cause
a hit reaction and got rid of a few bugs
on his character causing softlock so
sort of gonna clean them up Green Ranger
oh and across the board we've increased
any low hits you've sort of increased
the active time so that if I knock you
down and you're trying to hold up when
you're jumping it's gonna catch you a
long time the media trail right so and
so by increasing the active time on
locate sort of increases a track in
right we've changed a bit of the
hitboxes some of the his exs changed
I'll let you guys go through this a yeah
there's there's a lot of changes on the
characters please check it out battle
for the grid calm yeah the patch notes
they're also on Twitter their
attachments are floating around and yeah
like we said Twitter is so full of
information and combos and videos
there's also a pretty good discord going
yeah yeah yeah I can go almost 7000
people or something like that a very
active yet please find at this court
yeah and Twitter is such a great
resource not only for I don't feel too
great before all fighting games and
video games to find out
people that like to stuff that you like
oh yeah
Twitter's especially didn't yeah I mean
that's bound to happen
sure sure I mean that's a good thing
yeah it's a little scary because you
know we don't want you know your bugs
and all that yeah and with the patch
every new characters yeah three new
characters which we have all on the
screen ready for you Donna
she's from mystic force right sort of
like an icy character and fights with
her staff she's uh I would say she's
like a utility character so she has like
a lot more options than some of the
other characters in regards to sort of
like the angles that she can attack at
and all that her special moves of course
couldn't breathe right mind you be
careful about this but he has a little
bounce to it so especially when you have
her as an assist right extra films yeah
I always get I always get caught with it
because I forget about the little it
went through mine at eight - what so and
then also have her for DES which is a
sizable move yeah really good poke yeah
you can you can confirm it it's a super
if you manage to get and then her back
ass she is what we're calling an
eternally ice shield snow shield
you can get two of them if you sort of
mash it out you can only have two and
screen at once and also if you just let
it rock it will shoot out the ice for
you right so a good tactic is to call
the snow shield and then tag out is sort
of a jump jump snow attack shadows Chad
one of our animators he insisted on
having two different animations for
whether she's going forward or backwards
I love the detail yeah great yeah the
fancy pose and she also keeps the
momentum how excuse me sorry she keeps
the momentum when she does the attack of
whatever her jump is so if she jumps
yeah if she do hurt her - um she'll like
fly all the way across the screen and of
course you can use that in tandem with
just take over system so five my
assistant right
sort of like an air assistant yeah and
then her super taking space for scrutiny
mystic forest fans will know taken
straight from the source material
yeah she's so pretty yeah yeah she's
real easy to use like her her her
general fries other DLC character is
Cenozoic Blue Ranger is from anyone
that's familiar with the Power Rangers
2017 movies this person a little
familiar he's actually from the Cenozoic
era I don't want to spoil the movie but
he's he's pretty old yeah yeah yeah he's
so this character he sort of based
around this charge mechanic so he kind
of has his own way he can charge it by
pressing neutral s right was one charge
and you'll know that he's charged it
because his hands get electrified yeah
second charge she's all you know super
ready to go and if you charge again sort
of overload right shiz these pillars
know for DES and back s change depend on
depending on how much charge you have so
for the forest without the charge
it's alright sort of like a poke that
you can use excuse to end combos when
they do too much damage but still a
decent utility move back s puts this
lightning bolt out right sort of
defensively but if I have a charge ready
that press for it is I get this fireball
defense fireball yeah the best on the
game against our better judgment of this
fireball it hits five times super
durable super slow
anyone that has played a fighting game
knows that the slowest fireballs are the
most deadly right and then if I have a
charge up I press Bacchus I get to go
so extra extra cover and then RS if I
don't have any charge he charges up in
the air and if I do have a charge
pillows so we always tell the force
behind you and if I have two charges I
can do wild stuff like and e.x combo
this is my super really easy super to
use who I miss yeah with some time you
have to be really easy okay yeah if
you're a good player you'll get it yeah
so he's a character that it's it's
really good players with this character
are going to figure out how to get
charges and how to use them right and
you can store charges so right here I
have two charges ready so I can do my
slow fireball and then teleport because
it seems to me a way that I think what's
effective with him is that if I manage
to get one charge out if I get either
this fireball or if I get this double
lightning pillar out that sort of gives
me time to charge it right great right
so right I can charge this up and then I
can start teleporting around so good
player yeah it's really about learning
how to how to get charges how to use
charges he's cool and it has hitbox yeah
has hitbox as well yeah yeah good good
looking out you can do special combos
like in the corner you can do this good
[Laughter]
yeah so you can really do some some some
tricky stuff with him
yeah a really cool character and he's I
would say that you can really use them
sort of at a beginner level and advanced
levels he's really without any charges
he plays in out pretty much odd you
expect a very great like if anyone
that's familiar with Red Ranger he's
kind of like that teaches you about the
fundamentals of the game
this guy's sort of similar but the
charge right on to dragon armor tree me
so you'll learn about dragon armor trini
if you play the story mode but basically
she is Trini from Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers the original Yellow Ranger but
she has his crazy dragon armor on super
big super menacing yeah I don't normally
play huge characters like this but it
was really fun to figure out you know
what she should be doing in our game
wanted to make sure that she feels super
heavy I think we even have the screen
yeah the huge sound effect in the little
screen shake when she jumps she doesn't
run like the rest of the characters so
she doesn't yeah she walks if you hold
forward her - this is a menacing Walker
and she she she has has like a grappler
heavy fighting stuff but also has this
beam I want to make sure that she had
you know good space control twice with
the tail as well her target combos work
kind of differently than the other
characters and they so you can mash llll
but if you mash mmm that's our lawn
chair
big body combos yeah and then her her
heavy heavy target combo does the
stagger and you can come with that from
so what's it really interesting barriers
or specials right so her 4-2 missile
charge new and this is not air blockable
assault if you try to jump up the other
move which is this move you'll get
caught by so this is a command grab
right here you can jump out of it but
it's so thick it's super fast it goes
through stuff they both grow through
fireballs and this is the guessing game
right if I knock you down you're gonna
do this right or I'm gonna do the
missile charge maybe try to jump out of
the way and from from the jet rush
routes to the beckus can she combo she
can definitely combo so she can calm
over several ways depending it's gonna
be up to players to figure out where
they are on the screen when it hits so
if I'm like back here for example then I
want to combo using my [ __ ] beam but if
I'm closer to the corner like this
like that you can also can also jump
cancel it so fun closer to the corner
and then Herrera is this huge stomp hit
slow so you gotta yeah you got to be
careful right so I guess all the time
actually decide that why is that low I
get hit by all the time
so you can kind of trick your opponent
by jumping up and going you know on the
other side even right crossing up to the
other side it's a pretty nasty and of
course when you combine that persists
and all that it's really she becomes
really tough to block you really kind of
want to stay away from her of course her
has a huge positive for her super yeah
and her e^x combo and I could do that
into super power
she's cool man yes he's range right he's
damaged dang I've seen some combos on
Twitter what you touch go crazy if you
have full meter yeah and really yet it's
about utilizing - yes yeah so new
characters I mean again I want to make
sure that there's sort of something for
everybody you know and I think that
definitely see that and how different a
lot of these characters are from each
other yeah I think black like black
dragon treaties she really you know we
all know that there was players out
there who only put like super huge
characters so gets also one more thing
with her is for at the advanced players
so we have this take over system right
where if I get blue in my training says
she does the nega beam right but because
of the assist takeover system I can sort
of use whatever I want an assist so I
think my characters don't show it off as
well as some others but basically I can
call my assistant and then use either
the jet rush or the missile charge as
the move that she does when she tags out
I'm saying
epic yeah so she can be like off the
screen and like sort of flying flying
out of nowhere onto the screen and it's
really up to the players to tap into
your creativity when it comes to using
these attacks yeah it is cool because
it's like it might seem like it's simple
but that's what makes it more open-ended
because not just like the moves
themselves but the things you can do
like the take over system is cool
because you can either take over
immediately or you can let the assist
come out a little bit and then bring the
other person in which is cool to you cuz
that opens up a bunch of different
things yeah and a really easy mix up
that you can do is so in fighting games
the first thing that people do if I jump
up like this the first thing that people
do is they sort of stand up they want to
block
but if I have my assistant and this is
harder to block than it seems but if I
have my sister I go up and I start going
low immediately yeah if I'm jumping over
right and one of the one of the big
things you want to do is sort of get a
sandwich between your sister character
and and you with your pony in the middle
and then they don't know if you're gonna
write squish to the side and go low you
can get really really tricky really
creative with the mix ups and yeah
please
yeah patches out now one point two three
new characters when you see what you can
do with them yeah and if you guys won
and get more information battle for the
grid calm we got all the notes all the
updates you can also talk to the
community on the discord I'm sure you
can find that on Twitter pretty easily
also I kind of sent out the bat-signal
was like help and then everyone's like
go discord definitely goes it is the
discard check it out yeah shout out to
the community man for engaging for
giving us the feedback letting us know
what they want to see we're always
reading and always looking at it let us
know get the conversation started
and everyone tuning in right now thank
you so much for tuning in I know we've
been unloading a lot of information on
to you guys about this patch but we are
gonna open up into some lobby play soon
me and clock might get some matches in
also so if you guys have your game
loaded up and get your matchmaking ready
because we're gonna head over there for
some matches in just the [ __ ] and you
know everyone in the chat jake catfights
what's up how's it going Lee Matthew the
stream yeah just thanks for tuning in
like the fighting game talk all day I'm
here for it and I'm down for it and this
game is like a medley of so many
elements from other games that I like
and it's all indoors I was like really
good yeah it was important to us to be a
game that of course is the shout outs
all the Power Rangers fans upon a time I
used to wake up in the morning just to
watch Power Rangers oh actually in the
morning on weekends by after school
watch me some Green Ranger you know what
I mean and so for its for Power Rangers
fans and it's for fighting game fans and
it's for players who are sort of afraid
to play fighting games because they're
intimidated by the show's accessible and
so I've had people tweeting me out like
hey you know I've I discovered my first
like one touch killed combo or my first
mix-up is so awesome and obviously it's
really cool to see that people that
wouldn't normally explore the mechanics
of a fighting game or even a game have
done so much very accessible because you
know a fighting game in general can be
pretty daunting especially in games like
let me use Tekken as an example you know
down one forward one back one up one
down you know down forward one down back
one up forward one you know all these
different like like motions with the
button is all the different move but
like in this game
your light-attack you know forward back
that like down is use different foot
forward back you know those are gonna be
the same so it lets you take the time to
focus on your special attacks and stuff
like that which I think helps when it
comes to just if you're fresh the
fighting in you to fighting games and
stuff like that yeah yeah and although
all the moves are readily accessible as
players who are just jumping in the game
like I I can do all filthy casual asks
are the way Rhys stands work intentional
question so you know with our system
it's it's when we were when we were
designing sort of how the combos were
gonna working all that it we did notice
the Rhys tans but to be honest that I
feel like the reasons they do add sort
of another layer of calm way into the
game you know especially when the game
first launched a lot of the commas I saw
were like crazy
Rhys tans and all this like oh man we
really can't get rid of them now seeing
the stuff that people have come up with
Rhys tans and without reasons in his
it's pretty awesome so I would say
intentional in that we decided to not
remove them I like Rhys sins I just
wanna know if they were a happy accident
well you know quite a game trivia combos
where a happy accident emergent gameplay
is the merging gameplay exactly I mean
any fighting game player who's ever
spent even a minute in a lab knows all
the best setups came from an accident
you dropped the combo and you're like oh
wait I could get something over this
yeah but it's really cool and the thing
is that I feel like I've seen these
things with most of the characters of
the game just because the community has
really been delving in
the combo system and you know trying to
squeeze out every damage and hit the cab
like this one does a thousand but this
one does a thousand 34 I'm down with God
you were actually sure so when we first
got here
of course purrs oh she was sitting at
her just very diligently oh that you
know practicing some power Harry it was
already loaded up I saw the YouTube
video of my bald head on it oh yeah
she's doing her homework yeah you
actually showed me a resend
I didn't even know was in the game I
know yeah it's crouching em heavy heavy
and then medium medium and then loop
that oh and then I think I'm blue I have
to like walk for a little bit mature oh
yeah it was working better on the male
characters when I held forward and did
medium medium but female characters it
works pretty well
I had to plank the medium medium just to
get it to work most times there you go
yeah easy combat developer in a house
execution oh my god okay you free you
can loop that I think like four times
and then you in with medium medium or
heavy heavy and then CX and then
I don't even know how you figured this
hahaha winner shoutouts to I don't
remember it sort of handle but his
screen name was poverty and I was like
this is how I know this guy has all the
good tech restaurants ever see the hole
in the wall yeah oh one of the viewers
asked about ranked requirements and I
know earlier you were telling me to play
ring
there's also placing system yeah a
little bit about that sure I'll tell you
as much as I know you know very
complicated algorithms in place people
love however I do know that so you play
for matches first I guess CPU and then
it starts matching you against real
people though the second half is for
players right and for real players and
from there it places you against other
players who have you know in the same
bracket who have you know beaten online
play basically your your rank right yeah
yeah so you know it's not gonna match
you against if you're like you know some
huge rank is the matchmaking is based on
not only your rank also your region and
your latency
we want to make sure that we have the
best user experience for online play and
from what I've played and from feedback
that we've gotten the online connection
that was really good yeah I did Karen
that goes great yeah yeah I played the
other night and I think I had maybe one
match
all right so speaking of netcode let's
try some ranked battles let's try some
ring battles so anybody in the chat if
you want to play
please join go into your matchmaking
right now try to search with us we're
just going to go into the searching
matchmaking and keep it nice and quick
and easy yeah they want to play with you
the combat designer they gotta play some
see okay
so while you guys boot up your systems
we're gonna have clockwork get the cpu
placements out the way make my count
look good level zero
[Laughter]
go ahead snag this game believe it's 20
bucks right now on PSN with the free
update so three new characters stages
all that jazz first-rate yeah and we are
continuing to work hard on the game so
please and I mean you know some of us
fighting game players can relate but
having that continuous support for your
game it's just
irreplaceable show with the love and
what you love exactly
make love not worry except for when the
match starts
style on Tommy oh yeah when one change
that another have Red Ranger on let me
show you some changes so he has double
shot ons back role now is right so you
can go high-low a little high of course
but you just mash it and you'll get two
shots now he use that to set up Oh
reflecting a back at me over how could
you
also sort of a small change his his
stand H does not spike anymore right so
before that would spike down but now if
you hit it twice in spike down so sort
of opens up his combos addition also his
laser has been giving a bit of push back
on the pushes a bit more forward to air
laser so that you can sort of combo
easier if I press like LMS or MS I can
catch with the
standing em afterwards a bit you not for
nothing though when I was playing I
played a couple matches against the
computer in training mode got some
disrespectful a let me say that I was
like oh I can't jump
you scare me every time okay don't get
anything off of it but every time you're
like nope
get out no yeah these guys are protected
fired up right my placement matches are
going well oh it does it automatically
pic online what stage he goes here
that's a good question sorry combat
questions here only that is not a combat
question okay we found it yeah I was
doing some surgery on my hitbox in that
free damage no perfect sear
yeah that's probably my favorite thing
about fighting in like every fighting is
so different but they all have you know
the same fundamentally like punish man
ooh I do like combo system in the scenes
yeah the combo system it's really about
learning what your ground combo ground
options are what your juggles are and
then seeing how much you can push the
combo system so that you can still hit
pick an ax or a super or super oh yeah I
should mention a swap strikes are good
for Versalles damage in the ex obviously
but I still get to use defensively and
offensively if you're just trying to get
in a pesky assist or trying to kill a
character off or get rid of blue health
oh nice nice nice sound owl in the chat
asked what are the updates well you
must've just stood then but when our
pods are up on YouTube you should
definitely check it out because we did
go over a lot of the updates earlier and
the new characters now we're playing
some matchmaking so feel free to join in
on the matchmaking but yeah there's a
lot in the update so I'm sorry we can't
recap it all for you right this second
but definitely come back and check it
out the updates are awesome because it
includes not just a lot of bounce stuff
in combat but also story mode stages is
be awesome if you watch the video don't
mind our voice over actual voiceovers
are awesome
now you should be Zordon that I'm with
it oh yeah I was gonna say I want to see
some goo Donna anyway no Red Ranger
assist yeah and what's cool about Red
Ranger system really works well with the
takeover so I for those not in the know
you can take over by pressing your sis
button again at any time during the
assist so you can do it at the end of it
at the beginning of it and you can
cancel as long as it's not in the air
you can cancel whatever your assistive
tech is at the end into you know
movement or more attacking right so
normally Red Ranger can't normally Red
Ranger
Oh No so normally Red Ranger he can't
combo off of his his two hits of his
double slice but if he uses it as an
assist of like that right so suddenly
I'm on the other side so it's really
about as you get deeper into the
mechanics it's really about being clever
clever with takeover system
okay
was that three are we ready to fight the
online world
anyone else need replacement matches
right yeah I hope you guys got all your
placements out of the way because
clockwork is ready for battle
yeah I'm still level zero yeah
all right searching for an opponent I
mean I did see some fighting game heads
in the chat earlier so maybe and they
went to go set up and again big shout
outs to the to the vo that we got in the
game so again originally we had JDF the
original Green Ranger right awesome so
John Red Ranger let's go black track and
show all blacks let's go oh yeah when
you're color coordinated that's how you
know you're prepared okay now let the
intros Rock of course yeah we found that
match pretty fast so green stream is in
Chinese it
but Adonis's nice something about treaty
is a treaty is super huge so you can do
combos on here that you can normally do
on characters oh yeah the instant
overheads yeah really we really want to
take a vendor training at the same time
if you are treating you want to take
advantage of the anti air is being
reversals right hey my placement silly
yo can we get 10 out of 10 there we
great and then I retire my accounts and
when 10 out of 10 yeah but yeah like I
was saying to the vo yeah it's really
pouring bet all the grunts and the
yelling and the shouting oh man I know
I've never done voiceover work but I
think I feel like I felt like being a
voiceover for a fighting game is
probably hilarious because you have to
make all like this I imagine like the
death sounds there like like a street
fighters all the does sounds are crazy
the most like extended like battle cry
ever yeah hey I'm down I'm down you know
what when you make your next fighting
shrieking noises oh yeah I'll be great
so you perfect that's my that'll be my
battle cry intro intro alright so we got
our next match against puns raagh won
one for another Trini things people are
liking this character oh my god I had to
be cheap for a second wake up super now
we added their team that punish Oh
American resets Oh
playing the fluke you got this what you
want punch rogue I made this game oh
snap Red Ranger get out of there man but
what it does do is it amps up the the
trouble limiter right right so you can
do up select to Isis in the combo but
yeah I can't even get my full combo and
you can hit that assist towards the end
and don't try to follow up but you can
you can use that part for setups
oh that shot lady while y'all went
inside there in there that you try it
again
but the throws we play baton games sorry
alright alright alright man my
placements looking good oh yeah see ya
in the old patch you might be able to
call it dragons are right now all
sitting in but yeah when you have your
Megazord out you'll waste that time and
also if you call your Megazord when you
only have two characters left it doesn't
last as long as if you only have two one
character so you throw out this bounce
and between one I want to shut out the
other players Megazord but I also want
to have like the maximum time so you
know it's about how can I shut out their
Megazord and not having it backfire in
my face well suddenly they have one
character left with like the long
Megazord nice game yeah I forgot already
was but shoutouts of year and the times
Rock there we go Jake oh GG Jake
assuming that was you Oh possibly but
we'll see still searching right now
anybody want to join in some people are
probably doing there their placement
sauce yeah yeah but we've been finding
matches at a pretty good rate whoo
and we got another one greatness oh snap
magna
dragon armor trainee he's kind of
surprised yeah how does that feeling
when you start seeing people play and
you start seeing people pick certain
characters are you ever like surprised
like in [ __ ] or you would expect them
to pick like red ranger or something
yeah yeah I would you know I would
well when I've been playing online at
home I see a decent amount of Green
Ranger and a decent amount of gia of
Yellow Ranger but you know this is the
patch surprising to see a lot of dragon
armor trim because she's a big character
right oh yeah there is push block in the
game yeah three push block so you should
keep that in mind you have to hit Tess
yeah yes while you're blocking but the
window is not super generous so it takes
a little bit of timing you if you prime
it wrong you might you know with I
confirm that black this is why I'm here
you guys era of Monday through Friday
11:00 a.m.
GameSpy live Oh where's toner that was
good like you know I'm a fan of counter
characters cuz I feel like there's
always room to make people stop pressing
buttons I think he gave up like you know
what I'm over this and he's a power
ranger veterans almost let's get this
perfect score real quick let's get this
perfect square real quick
Tommy Oliver played by Jason David Frank
has been in over 200 episodes level 108
characters all the kick is let's go what
these characters can do this is team 1.2
new and improved I liked it he was on
theme okay
Crescent family with the green dragon
dragon Zord motif oh he's going right at
me okay okay
laptop president button woo she's still
got her eyes fall out ooh okay
that Tommy is
now that was for testing purposes yes
how much this game cost cost 20 bucks
plenty back so you know it definitely is
20 bucks with three free characters yeah
come on here in San Francisco that'll
get you half a lunch you know what I'm
saying
so surely yeah bad felonies this is the
eighth match greatness again the run
back Louisville City
hairy's commentary table says I love how
accurate Oh Donna is to the show yeah
that's what's up do you want to make
sure that these characters are love
letters offends you know we're Power
Rangers fans as well and greatness you
playing greatness greatness where you at
man snoozing on your qualifying match
this is important no this is just for
all the marbles game number eight I'm
gonna in game number eight with a
perfect they're about to rank me way too
high I dunno probably rate of course
right so it's a XO Academy Power Rangers
version I mean you can totally say this
is not your department okay
likely I will well that's the eSports of
this game looking like question but III
know that there have been a few
tournaments not only local tournaments
but also we even featured at a Wednesday
night fights you know both here in
NorCal and in SoCal
I was watching Michigan Masters which is
recently a huge turbo everyone's
screaming all that I can't speak to
their sobriety but they're getting hype
awesome Power Rangers so yeah if you
want to see you know more events more
eSports for this game yeah let us know I
got gold one what's the highest what's
the highest ring do you know or is that
also nothing more phenomenal ring I'll
let you know when I gets very well yeah
you know I would really like to see what
it's really interesting to see what high
level play looks like in any game you
know whether it's a fighting game
whether it's you know any other video
games be running and all that and
Power Rangers battle for the grid it's
no exception that really love to see and
have been seeing what high level play
looks like people hitting their anti-air
is doing crazy combos calling both
assists at the same time and then
switching to one side or the other yeah
I love all of that wacky stuff chorus of
course if you guys know the games that
we played you know the business rate of
our ally all right so I think we should
try to sneak in maybe like two one or
two more matchmaking and then we'll play
something of each other so you said
you're set on yes right now Kat we Dona
CBR I'm sorry yeah I don't know if I'm
totally sold on TV I'm I am actually
using it because his assist is so good
this is really good so I might stick
with him for now yes good thing is his
assist it's it's you can use the
fireball it's just charts fireboxes
using it without the charge yeah so you
can call the assist have him shoot out
the fireball and then switch over to him
so you kind of get to run behind the
fireball but the fireball as an
assistant only hits three times as
opposed to five times when he's on point
oh snap booty games in the chat welcome
thanks for joining us
he says that we've been shouting up this
card yes we have and I think catfights
also been holding it down with directing
people there as well but thanks for
tuning in if you are near your ps4 you
should hop in and try to get some
matches with clock because we're gonna
take about one or two more and then
we're gonna run some sets and then
that's gonna be it for our show today
shout out every one that we played
online so far yeah
ooh match found let's go who's a dark
furious level 57 the green v two's game
noise noise and the Dragon shield I see
a lot of the Dragon shield Red Ranger
all you got what do you got all right
let's see bring it bring the action look
at you guys with your full screen assist
calling okay
guys fighting back get off man I know
leave her alone she's too pretty
ooh the black chains Oh with punish and
you could choose to follow up with
lacrosse under in the corner et it's
extra tricky right it was like some
games Canyon good suicide oh that was
scary
yeah you kept him alive though we should
ask the combat designer see I wouldn't
be able to make a game because I would
be getting body by you guys and I'll be
nerfing all your characters all day yeah
a wise man once told me that once this
game was that actually my D told me that
once this game was out I'm gonna have to
try my best I'm gonna have to resist
every urge to just nerf everything and
trust players to get around
I'm gonna take that man shaitana yeah
that's some pretty sage advice I'm not
gonna lie because you know there there
are some things that obviously that's
wrong but then there's other things
that's like ah you know except to play
smart you know to get around this thing
and there ain't about to lose ooh Donna
Oh wild a little bit what he press
you're gonna do it so funny okay so if
our dark Sirius has definitely been one
of our most challenging opponents thus
far no figures the first match Oh
this proves how good you know this fancy
algorithm what're you talking about
we've made it out of placements and now
we've matched up with people closer to
our skill range looks like a chain to
jump
knees knees look at one character left
nice to beta debate nice games are
furious yes that was good okay it's
gonna match my record still strong
anybody just tuning in we did go over a
bunch of update notes we talked a bit
about the new characters we played a
couple matches out of story mode so if
you're just tuning in now I definitely
recommend to watch the videos later
because it's pretty fun I've been having
a great time so far chillin with the
homie clockwork and Matthew Williams
thanks for that yeah thanks for the
words of encouragement
[Laughter]
yeah and shout outs to the fgc homies
coming to the chat checking it out
showing support
yeah shout outs the fighting games and
those who play them agreed sure will fam
1427 level 81 using my girl Kat let's go
green dude you know I definitely only
picked Kat because I love rekha
characters and I was like this is
probably as close as I'm gonna get so I
reckon you can mix it up so you can do
like so her Rekha is neutral SSS maybe
don't ask back ass s4s which is pretty
cool cuz you do it like forward nestled
to assist and show like cross it's so
like don't let your dreams be dreams it
probably works can't dispense ice okay
okay noise oh it's cute isn't it the
pseudo shield reset and styling Oh relax
somersault into freeze
Oh yellow ranger she's kinda buck you to
because like I was playing this the CPU
version and she was just whooping me
oh yeah the eros it's uh it's pretty
dangerous whether you are real person or
no and I got smacked with her extremely
slow like low high at least three times
before I was like oh wait the second hit
is an overhead
oh my god so when the danger comes up
that means already accident is on its
way
prepare yourself
but now gone he's gone oh yeah also
shout outs to switch for like having a
lot of fighting hands on it more
fighting games than I expected there to
be when they originally announced the
switch cuz I was like man what am I
really gonna buy the switch for and then
all these fighting games came out and I
was like this is what I need yeah you
know what we got 10 minutes left of the
show let's play a little bad do I fix my
buttons however we can note that hey
nice games to everyone that joins us
online GG is our opponents we face once
we made it out of the placements yeah
really good matches many fierce battles
oh yeah so it's there we go
satis everyone to chat me yes seriously
thank you for tuning in man this update
is pretty cool it's like almost like a
brand new game but it's not so that's
exciting and I think the even more
exciting and underrated thing Oh
besides you know that side select with
the controllers because and that enhance
any ways support man's support
there's developer support for this game
and it's gonna keep on coming from the
looks of it you got people like clock
and shady holding it down for the combat
design which means you already know it's
about to be him and that's why we love
it so let's check on the stage yeah new
staging zone havoc in the chat what's
good re stands are still a thing all the
Reese tens we want to see everyone
standing up alright let's give this a
shot
maybe it yak Adam I have some problems
against race characters
okay I have my bet the wrong no yeah
shoutouts everyone the check you know
you know shady and I were on Twitter and
also the official battle for the grid
Twitter you know tweet us what you you
know it's at battle number four also we
hang on the disc or chat too so please
hit us up and shout save us for all the
support
the defense thing I feel like I've been
to heaven to get India's so I think if
you're mid screen you want to do it
after the second hit and that's a corner
uh yeah goes the fireball huge recovery
if it misses
it's really good oh my god no
okay I'm sorry oh sure okay
oh my god Oh No yeah just that funny
give big right where will you play
Gabrielle bass like you like blank
okay okay you say my dear
Oh
[Music]
oh man I keep forgetting it's down oh
yeah I was like I haven't even like
trying to do nothing yet yeah yes
bonuses when you have at least one
character dead and also the activation
is invincible so if your app today you
can block keep a bar right away
[Music]
now we're just you know taking this time
to admire Ranger
while we take a moment to get our P's
and Q's in order we're starting to wrap
up soon but we're still gonna play a
couple of minor matches
we went over so much update stuff and
it's just been awesome having a me and
guys try this game play this game and
it's fun if you like vs fighters you're
definitely gonna like this game and
there's kind of been a lot of vs.
fighters coming out recently it was like
infinite and BB tag and you know
obviously vs games that have been around
for a while now like schoolgirls and
marvel some of the classics yeah yeah
and of course everyone tuning in and all
the familiar faces and the new people
who stopped by thank you all the FGCU
homies thank you appreciate ya hey
Matthew illness has an interesting
question he says what was your favorite
character to make clawford who's the
hardest and we have the roster here
right now I would say that favorite
characters you know I'm a Mighty Morphin
fan so I really like red and green when
we were designing these characters
they're sort of meant to be like Ryu and
Ken Vienna so they teach you the
fundamentals of the game how the game
works and they're easy to use I have
deeper stuff if you want to explore that
and difficult I would say maybe Cenozoic
blue because you know the the Power
Rangers in the movie they you know they
have the cool-looking armor and all that
but as far as that the action goes
though doing you know on a typical Power
Ranger martial arts stuff I wanted to
sort of spice up the design for for that
character and that's what he had like
the energy there's a challenge but I'm
pretty happy with the way it turned out
Yugi game says I'm sure I speak for
everyone when I say I hope this game
makes it to the main stage one day soon
you're on the main stage right now yeah
thanks so much
all right let me try to do my dang combo
yeah you got homework to do Sam I do
yeah whatever I want to see all the
advanced combos next time I'm here oh
yeah you can cash up
oh oh I just did it too early
oh man
nobody maybe
all the Sochi I could get the arrows
all the party tones again with EXO if
you don't
oh man there's so much crap on screen
are you new Donna play Jesus no she's
gonna hear all day yeah money they ready
saying it I need to get him out that's
not like that though
[Laughter]
Oh oh nice timing we're gonna hit them
both oh my god what happened to my life
No oh my lord
my tiem it melted your girl got killed
like I like it happy birthday because of
damage is so high sure you get a super
some way somehow yeah when you have you
greatly its unskilled on both of them
it's not a little it's it's this it's as
if you were hitting one character
experience oh so it doesn't scale up
just because you have two characters
wah-wah no I tried no it's bad I needed
him
cannot grab a frozen character Oh
I pressed a button
so like V&V oh no that's cool not that
birthday one
oh man no
let's go
well I crossed myself oh all right one
more take one more ass-whooping real
quick yes quickly like this
oh we also added that you can skip intro
now so he's trying to get back into
action
oh my god oh the loop that's not the
same
Oh
you know I'm still blocking in there
even though I know all the conversion
[Music]
oh my gosh yeah it takes forgetting uses
a block there she's super punishable if
you do block it but
Oh got my cross up
oh yeah dragons wasn't in mystic tours
but helping me out anyway yeah all right
you guys well there it is we played some
battle for the grid and we got to talk
all about the new update we got to see a
little bit of story mode you guys got to
witness the glory that is our voiceover
work as well so thank you guys so much
for tuning in and hey try this game outs
20 bucks right now the updates free all
three new characters are free and it's
really fun if you've never played a
fighting game before competitively I
definitely recommend giving this one a
shot because it's a lot more accessible
a lot more easier to get into and I
guarantee like most people who barely
pick up fighting games the second you do
you're gonna be hooked and then you're
gonna be one of us but yeah thanks so
much guys be sure to tune in gamespot
live Monday through Friday at 11:00 a.m.
and we'll catch you guys next time
you